At Stellina's Pizzeria in D.C., the food has been hot,...
...and the tips steady throughout the pandemic.
Have the tips been good during the pandemic?
Oh, for sure.
But now, the staff, suppliers, customers, everyone is facing a tipping point.
And service workers in some places are paying the price.
Just ask Isabella Sarmiento, the Operations Manager.
Tipping has grown a lot more complicated.
It has. You are not wrong.
The pandemic by many accounts pushed tips to new prominence in home deliveries,...
...at take-out stands, food trucks, and in ride-sharing services,...
...far beyond the spots where many consumers were used to seeing them.
At the New York Times, food writer Christina Morales says...
...that's left a lot of folks wondering, where to tip, when, and how much.
What's driving really a lot of this anxiety and confusion,...
...is the fact that these changes in tipping have happened so fast.
She says even the social norms for tipping have become unsettled,...
...noting one company, which tracks credit card transactions,...
...found tips rose as the pandemic began, then leveled off,...
...and now are falling amid the confusion and inflation.
So, should you tip at a coffee stand, a supermarket, a convenience store?
I'm a good tipper.
Some customers say it's simple.
If someone helps you, tip.
If you help yourself,...
I was at the airport, and I grabbed a bottle of water from like a convenience store,...
...and asked me for a tip,...
...and I was like, uh, that's not happening.